hello my name is john regan the CEO of
all from mathcore developers of system
modular in this presentation that will
show how you can use our dwie nose
together with system over to create
experiments in your labs ok thank you
phil and so as Phil said
hardware-in-the-loop simulation is my
first presentation ever when i'm using
any hardware except my computer so i
guess i will see if I'm the first one to
get something to work the first time I
run something some hardware anyways this
presentation of work together with
laguna leonardo laguna race 1 our
developers developers inland shipping he
he likes arduino raspberry PI's and
similar stuff quite a lot so it does a
little bit of experiment experiments at
home and at the end i will be displaying
one of his creations which is this bowl
beam here not there before i do that i
will start with an overview of
connectivity in the system order and
then i'll give the arduino example
including this one and a couple or more
before i wrap up with a very short
coming soon section for the things that
will mention here on connectivity some
of them are will just briefly mention
some i will will show an example of and
but the focus will be on arduino so
first first of all if you have a system
model model you can always export it and
there's two ways main ways to export it
you can either export it as a simulation
executable so when you have your model
every time you you simulate it it's it
creates a c code and that c code or c++
actually is then compiled that
executable you can use in any way you
like without any licence conditions from
our side if you're using any library
that has specific license conditions to
it then of course you have to apply to
those and i actually saw one example of
that today at the additive booth where
smart CAE was develop
a simulator using the executable behind
the scenes but you can also use the FM
use which is a standardized interface a
functional mock-up unit that makes it
possible to export to a lot of different
tools so we can look at that list here
for some examples meaning that if you
have a model in system over and want to
use it in for instance answers employer
or in a car maker or in general energy
systems and I very stand and so on you
can just click fmi export it will export
your so called f mu which you can import
in that too and use it as part of their
system and so to to make this a little
bit more easier to understand I'll show
you an example for from ni very sad so
basically here is an illustration on set
up we have a model of some tank system
that is developed in system order and
and for those of you that have run the
introductory examples in system mode
you'll probably run that model because
it is just a system of three tanks where
the level levels of the tanks are
governed by some controller once that
has been developed it is deployed or
exported to the fmu and with the fmu we
import that to ni very stand and ni very
stand is from National Instruments and
and the purpose of that is to test for
real real-time performance so basically
by getting into ni very stand you can
test it how will perform together with
different hardware and then deploy it to
hardware so basically i will not i don't
have an ivory stand on my computer so i
cannot run it live but i can at least
show you kind of the type of result you
can get from that and this is the ni ver
east end user interface where you can
build up systems like this with knobs
and and plots and the interesting thing
here is not the interface itself but
that is actually testing things for
real-time
real-time performance so we'll get a
report telling you whether it would work
for your application not whether you
need to improve performance of your
model based on that you can take the
result back to system owner and develop
the model further if you need or perhaps
you see that you have a lot of margins
you can do a more advanced model more
detail model and then you do that and
you can go back to annoy Barry stand and
verify that it will work and deploy that
but as I said that's just one example
there are several other tools that can
import these FM eyes making it possible
to create a complete word full but also
sometimes you would like to you have
some work you have done in some other
two and you want to import it to sister
modeler and then you can do that with
the same fmi functionality but using the
import functionality of it so tools that
can export FM eyes are amongst others
listed some here including an sis Kaede
in IBM rational Rhapsody a control build
and so on so by developing something in
one of these tools you can then use that
in system or burn so why would that make
sense let's illustrate that with an
example from our fierce competitor
simulink so simile is used especially
within the control systems we will own
control system design so there's a lot
of controllers designed in simulink and
in this case what we'll have is a
drivetrain model that has been developed
in system model and we want to use a
controller developed in simulink so let
me run that in simulation center as I as
that has been exported if am i from SEMA
link i really don't need I don't have
similar link on my computer but here is
the model and you see there in the
middle of something something missing
that's the fmu that I haven't imported
yet but if I click in to this here we
see the system older model of the drive
rain with the transmission and Driver
and so on this is something I've shown
in previous presentations so I want to
go in previous years I won't go into
details how the model itself works
that's not really the topic of this
presentation but what I will do is how I
will import this FM you import FM you
from SEMA link and a cruise control like
that and now up lights me there you go
so here I have imported that and
actually I have to we can see here that
I had predefined the controller here in
the system and then it will pop up in my
model so now i have the Similan
controller controlling my drive line and
high some input seeing a very simple
reference signal there that i can use
and i can then simulate that from within
system over without any need of SEMA
link or any other software it's just it
knows everything that was from the same
old model and can run it here so this by
the way what was going on here is
compiling the simulation code the thing
I mentioned first so that executable
that was compiled now is the one that
you can use for deploying and creating
your own simulators now I can plot let
me close this so we have a little bit
more conceal a bit better I can plot the
referee speed but I can also plot the
measured speed of the car and in this
case I can see for instance if i zoom in
somewhere that we have we lose some some
speed every now and then and I guess
most of you can guess what's going on
when that happens anyone why is that
happening Gary ship yeah and if it would
have been andreas driving the gearshift
would that mean was much smoother is a
very good driver so it would work much
better
okay so that shows the the reason why
you would like to import something to to
system all are you you might have parts
a model like a controller for a simulink
that you want to reuse you don't want to
redo that but you want to use the full
potential of system modeling to folder
plant and then you can develop that plan
to the car in this case and add the
controller from simulink for this I want
to an example that you can also to the
model like a code call external
functions so in the Malacca code you can
reference to dll's in to see files and
basically that means to anything that
can be wrapped into a see file so any
code you have that can be wrapped in to
see file you can reference to that in
the model like a model and compile it
with entire model so if you happen to
have some kind of algorithm developed
for what do I know like a lookup table
that you're using for for something then
you can can plug that in to the model
like a model and run it ya see as if it
was modelica you can also communicate
with executable itself so once you're
running you can connect to it through a
tcp/ip protocol so anything that can
speak tcp/ip you can query the
simulation for different things like
queries for results but you can also set
things like start stop time pause
restart and change inputs so you might
have for instance connect in some kind
of the device let's say in a gamepad to
your computer and have that to control
your simulation so that you can use the
tcp/ip protocol for so let's see here
and one example here which you could use
for that is you could develop your own
custom applications in any kind of
software in this case somebody has
generated some software there on the on
the left hand side where he uses that to
kind of as which displays the results
but also by pushing in different places
changes parameter values and it goes to
the model runs that and feeds the
information back
okay so now we're getting getting there
so model plug was added I think about
four months ago something like that and
perhaps more but the ideal in model plug
is to be able to connect to Arduino or
any board that uses a different matter
protocol so to easily connect to a
tweener board how many here knows what
an Arduino is almost everyone how many
have used an Arduino quite a lot okay so
typical when you use Arduino you have to
well you do some some wiring and stuff
and you create your experiment and then
you have the code the communication for
it the idea with this with this is by
using the model plug library you will be
able to connect that with drag-and-drop
so let me just show the web page first
for the model plug library so basically
with the model plug library you will be
able to create different examples and I
will show these examples soon it would
create a robot arm or inverted pendulum
and use that it you can you can download
it and it's it's it's free so this
screen resolution is not the best but
you can see it's a free download so it's
just download it and then you can use it
for whatever purposes you would like to
have it so let's start with before we go
live I think that it's a wait for that
to last so the thing you might remember
is that I've failed that the last thing
I did so this is an one example of
something you can set up we are built a
robot arm and some control panel with
some knobs to control that robot arm you
could connect the control panel directly
to the robot but what will happen then
is that the signals from the control
panel are pretty rough which means that
that robot
we'll move and very like a was a kind of
opposite of smooth I'm losing words here
as so we will kind of jump from one
place to another so you want to filter
the signals in some way and then so this
is the simplest example of what you
could be doing with the system modular
the model plug models so you have this
system here the board and then just a
couple of filters for the signals and
then the robot arm and what I will do is
I will just show a video of how it how
it works we'll see the actual library
and example live soon I just wanted to
give you some examples of things you can
do so here you can see that we have the
robot we have the plate with knobs this
is connected to computer and what we see
here is simulation center and we are
plotting I think it's the position in X
Y Z direction for some point of the
robot and you can plot whatever you
would like to just as you would do in
any system of our simulations so if i
run this you will see that data plots
are there and you can see the robot is
it's moving it's not that easy to see
but it's actually adding you see here
it's adding information as we go on the
plot
another example and I kind of like this
is that that one which was a lot
hardware and very little software in
this case we're going the other way
around we're doing this model here where
we have an accelerometer and we connect
that to a model of an inverted pendulum
and then we try to you to use the
accelerometer to give the pendulum
disturbances and see how how well it can
control itself so let's look at that by
the way on their way here we are then
the most classical of course is to do
the blinking LED and have a type how the
world as you saw on on a Raspberry Pi
presentation early on and let's of
course something you could do here too
so here we have accelerometer and we can
see the system of our model where the
inverted pendulum is is moving in order
to balance a or your pendulum and
accelerometers is not any it's not that
good so it's actually a little bit hard
to give it exactly signals you want but
you can implement it better and then you
then of course what you can do here is
to develop to have an exercise for the
students or for yourself how do i do to
develop the controller in order to
actually balance this as good as
possible or you could do some other
experiment using that as a reference
where do I want to move my my pendulum
is rather than say then hitting with it
or we might have another one to tell it
the reference position or whatever you
want to add to make the system more
complex so let's look at the balancing
balancing a ball on this one here so
before we actually use the hardware I'll
will take a check look at the model
here's the 3d version modeling system
model so of course there oh that was not
what I was aimed to of course we have
modeled this in in in system hablar also
completely so without any hardware to
begin with but anyways here here is the
model we have if I click into this we we
can see that this is that we know board
and Arduino board is basically
communicating we have which pin or servo
are we connecting to with pin to a port
and this is the card itself the Arduino
board and and we are telling it which
port it should connect to so if we go up
to upper level here we see that the only
thing we have done is drag and drop
together the different pins and the
different ports who are using and we're
setting up basically which port is it
I'm supposed to talk to in this case I
hope it's Conine still it might change
sometimes and then I have to
which one it has changed to so you just
set up the only kind of program you need
to do is to write down which port to
communicate with nothing else okay so
let's try to run this
hopefully this will I have to set it up
to run real time I guess for infinity
and synchronize with real-time like that
now hopefully when i run this oh sorry
we'll have something happening there
yeah okay so now we see it actually
doing something so basically in the
model what we have we have set a
reference point for where we want this
ball and then the controller is inside
my computer is a system over simulation
and then when I move the ball of course
it tries to get it back and it's
actually pretty good at doing that so
that was interesting work the first time
so now you might amount might want to
experiment with stuff what happens if I
like that kind of manage to do that but
you might want to start looking at
things within them in the model itself
so let us try here to design another
controller quickly and that just by
changing parameters I go into the
parameters for for the controller here
and go to let's say well let's say that
we start with the easiest one if we if
we change the P part the proportional
part what would we expect anyone from
controls what would we expect if we
change the proportional part well it's
actually pretty bad because the
proportional part is the most important
so it doesn't really achieve what we
wanted to achieve so let's stop that
again and switch back then we can change
something else like the derivative part
and I have no idea what would happen
here let's sit let's put it let's
increase that will probably not work
that well I to knows it's kind of not as
good as the original one but it's
hopefully making its work it's at some
point in time okay so what's a bad
controller yeah but in this way you can
experiment in test different controllers
and of course to design the controller
you can use the control functionality
Mathematica and that's what what has
been done when they do
signed other controller so i'm i'm
pretty sure that i will not be able to
buy random find a better controller than
the one that is is right now do it there
to put the bowl here stop it there you
go okay there so you get the idea here
it's quite easy and all of these things
are a low cost so it's a simple arduino
board where they have done some kind of
wiring put puts a few capacitors and
things on it connected that and then
connect this hardware with a servo which
you can control you control the
servicing they'll formed arduino board
and that will control the angle in this
here we have a couple of sensors which
are basically light sensor so they are
measuring the distance of the ball and
that is what you need to set up and then
you have connected to two system over
using the model plug library and you
have your your experiment going on
immediately so it's kind of up to your
fantasy and you're in you're in the kid
in yourself to come up with good
experiments that will teach you stuff
and then you can hop here you can i can
change the reference position and so on
there is there's tons of things i could
do so and that is what i was going to
show with the arduino and i have like
two minutes left I think and for that I
will say call me soon so coming soon is
a similar library but in a sense we say
is the professional model plug it's for
basically for process industry mostly so
there's a standard OPC the process
industry which is used for data
communication so in the very same way as
the model plug is used by drag and drop
in this case you will use half-dragon
drops components for OPC and instead of
connecting to this guy here you will
perhaps connect to a brewery or I don't
know what you would like to connect you
I would be interested in controlling
that at least or or produce or how was a
ethanol production or
have your printer etc you can you can
printing press you can any kind of
process industry would have the OPC OPC
apply to the OPC standard and then you
can do similar things like controlling
the actual plant from sister mugler
using the OPC protocol or you can just
use it to monitor so you read signals
from it and then you might have models
that can predict what is going to happen
in the future you might have let's say
you have a thousand sensors out there
and then you want to understand what
will happen in different scenarios which
scenarios could could happen based on
the information you receiving then you
can simulate that and predict different
alternatives depending on pulling in
perhaps data from from from Wolfram
Alpha on all from weather data to see a
projection room where we are heading how
we should control the system and so on
and but in principle works the very same
way as this one just on a larger scale
and slightly more expensive so with that
I'll thank you very much and hope you
have a good end of this conference thank
you